when you were violent you play to the
critics who want to say oh they're all
violent looters they're all a criminal
element and that actually defeats the
righteousness of the message mr. Floyd
was nonviolent he was nonviolent against
the police the crime that they were
possibly investigating was a non-violent
crime violence actually demeans the
situation and Leeds loses the righteous
indignation and I would urge the
protesters to respect the curfew because
the curfew is necessary because the
police have a real job of policing
dealing with the looters and the looting
is criminal behavior pure and simple
there's no righteousness there's no
message there's no indignation these are
opportunists who see the police are busy
dealing with the protesters and they say
well here's an opportunity to loot and
to steal and to cause mayhem that's all
they are this is criminal behavior
period designed to create chaos well
there are anarchists in there also fine
it's all illegal behavior and we will
not allow our cities in this state to be
in chaos period Public Safety is rule 1
maintaining order is rule 1 it's not
going to happen in the state of New York
we're not going to allow the looting
that we've seen on videotapes the chaos
that we've seen period the police must
be empowered to keep order stop the
looting and stop the criminal activity
distinguish between the protesters and
the looting yes you have police action
which is necessary
to work with the protesters but the
police have to be there and be empowered
to stop the looting and the chaos and
the criminal behavior that people are
trying to exploit this moment for their
own selfish criminal purposes and the
police have to be able to do their job
and the police have to be supported in
being able to do their job
I've sent New York State Police to
cities to deal with these protests they
have to have the right numbers they have
to be empowered to do their job and
we've had protests again last night all
across the state I want to applaud the
local police who have done a great job I
want to applaud the State Police who
have done a great job the protests were
mainly peaceful all across the state and
I want to thank all involved for keeping
it that way protesters included New York
City last night was much better the
protesters were mainly peaceful the
police officer had the resources and the
capacity to do their jobs and the
results last night were much much
different than the night before and
that's what it's all about and I think
the people in New York City should feel
much better today than they did after
the night of looting these are perilous
times there's a lot going on and we have
to understand what's going on and the
the difference among the issues that
we're dealing with you have the Cova
crisis you have the murder of mr. Floyd
two very different situations but both
critical in and of themselves and both
happening at the same time it's then
wrapped in an environment and a dynamic
that is racially charged and politically
charged it makes it a very very perilous
time in this country and we have to be
careful we have to be very careful
because the concept
winces are steep on both sides of this
equation so leadership good government
responsibility is more important than
ever before especially in these divided
times Co 419 is still a real threat
we're still battling that I know it's
not on the front pages today but it is
still in people and in society we're
still battling that that is going better
than it has ever gone in New York we
have the lowest number of
hospitalizations ever and we have the
lowest death toll ever and god bless the
people of New York for what they did
god bless the nurses and the doctors and
the essential workers and the frontline
workers because they saved hundreds of
thousands of lives in the state of New
York we have to remember what made us
successful during kovat that were New
York tough but New York tough is is
multifaceted
it means New York smart if you're going
to protest protest intelligently
remember the kovat virus is still out
there
so protest intelligently we're United
we're not black and white
we're not upstate downstate we're not
red and blue we are one state one
community and we came together that way
we're disciplined in fighting this kovat
we're disciplined in having our right to
protest but doing it peacefully and in a
way that respects law and order and we
are loving at the end of the day yes we
have issues yes we have challenges but
we've shown how good we can be as a
community and how much we respect one
another and the sacrifice we're willing
to make for one another let's keep that
spirit that we developed over the past
95 days let's keep that going because
that is pure magic if we stay united and
we stay loving
and we stay smart we're going to handle
all of these issues and we're going to
be the better for it we've overcome the
greatest challenge that this state has
faced in my lifetime with this covert
virus
this was the beast that we didn't know
if we could be but so far we've beaten
it we have to stay smart to make sure we
control the beast but we did it we
overcame we the people over came
together last words for today do not be
overcome by evil but overcome evil with
good
Romans 12 that my friends is New York
tough smart United disciplined and
questions need to change culture within
local police agencies and the wider
criminal justice system your policy
ideas don't really hit at the issue why
aren't bad apples being called out by
colleagues and will you allow the
release of state troopers disciplinary
records under 50 a well you have a lot
in there
there are necessary reforms that need to
be made there's no doubt about that
that's I hope the positive legacy of the
injustice that was done to mr. Floyd
many of those policies are already law
in the state of New York
50 a the disciplinary records I hope
will become law shortly and we have to
respect everyone's interests there and I
look forward to doing that and I think
the legislature is prepared to do it and
I think they're going to be coming back
in the next couple of weeks to have
those conversations
the police unions specifically of
something the mayor has talked about
sort of trying to change the culture how
do how do you know as governor what's
your role in sort of trying to get local
agencies to start thinking about this
idea yeah I don't know what the mayor
was referring to so let me find out what
he said and then I'll comment
appropriate that some obvious reference
to what the president did on Monday what
he said it was yeah that's where was
obvious what do you say even if I didn't
say it you would have figured it out
absolutely of course Oh what do you make
of the president's recent recent attacks
on New York what do you think he's
trying to do there is he trying to rile
his base is he trying to make legitimate
criticisms about your stewardship of the
state as well as the city well far be it
for me to psychoanalyze the President of
the United States I have a law degree I
have no medical degree as I told you and
I have no degree in psychoanalysis it's
nothing new for the president he's not
just attacked New York and tweets his
policies have been vicious to New York
he changed the tax code in a way that
increased the taxes in New York and
other democratic states he has failed to
do anything positive for New York he's
gone out of his way to be negative to
New York now why you know is it politics
who knows that's for someone else to
answer but the negativity forget the
tweets you know who cares about the
Queens and what he's done to the people
of the state that bothers me what he did
with salt refusing to fund urgent
transportation projects that hurt the
entire Northeast like the Hudson tunnels
stopping the second Avenue subway I mean
all these egregious acts kicking us out
of the trusted traveler program with
that DHS Department of Homeland Security
just as punitive
policy because they don't like that we
won't give them the driver's licenses
for undocumented people so they punished
us with the trusted traveler program I
mean that's there's a whole from day one
in his administration you have seen
negative hostile government acts and
then by the way the most recent if
refusal to fund state governments which
is negative to New York but it's also
negative all across the board yes we
there have been good things helping us
with Javits and the with the Army Corps
of Engineers and the additional beds
that was very helpful and look I said
from day one I'm not playing politics
with the president when he does the
right thing by New York I say he did the
right thing by New York Democrats don't
like me to say that it's the truth when
he does a bad thing for New York I say
it does they did a bad thing and it's
good and sped I I think I was in the
White House last week we had a meeting
yeah I don't think you should use active
military for political purposes I don't
believe it's constitutional and now you
have his Secretary of Defense saying
that they shouldn't be used now how can
the Secretary of Defense say that and
then do it that's another question if
you don't believe it's right when you
pull up secretary Esper's quote again
there please if you don't believe it's
right why did you do it you can't do it
and then say I think it's wrong so you
just admitted that you did something
that was wrong we look at this quote
the option to use active duty forces and
a law enforcement role should only be
used as a matter of last resort and only
in the most urgent ioser we are not in
one of those situations now I do not
support invoking the insurrection act
then how did you do it mr. secretary
question for him not for me what were
they in the question was about active
military and Watertown National Guard
are different than active military
personnel for political purposes
National Guard we deploy for public
purposes we deploy them to help with a
covert virus we deployed them for storm
emergencies if they were deployed for
New York City that's not a political
purpose that's to help the police
function in New York City so that's
those are not political purposes but we
did not send the National Guard in New
York City I said yesterday that there
was a terrible night of looting I was
prepared to send the National Guard to
help to provide the resources if the
city needed them but I said I don't
believe the NYPD needs the National
Guard they're the largest police force
in the United States of America like
thirty six thirty thousand people so I
don't believe they needed the National
Guard I believe believe there was an
issue of management and deployment of
the NYPD you know you have to remember
the NYPD first on a personal level I
grew up in Queens you know I grew up
with the N white
you know my neighborhood a lot of my
friends became police officers in New
York City it's the best little New York
arrogance but I believe it's the best
Police Department in the country and we
know the police officers can handle
these situations because they have right
we've gone through the Sean Bell
situation we've gone through the
aftermath of amadou diallo aftermath of
Abner Louima we went to Crown Heights
the Gavin Cato death and then we went
through the aftermath of Crown Heights
it was a whole report done on Crown
Heights
that studied what happened it was like
four or five days of riots so we we've
done this you know this has been there
done that for the police the police
officers know how to do it these are the
best now a police officer needs support
they need the right deployment they need
to be empowered they need the capacity
to do their job they have to know that
they're backed up they have to know that
if they're out there they can do what
they have to do if they have to arrest
somebody they have to arrest somebody
they have to have the right gear so they
have to get the support that they need
but they're the the it's not about being
YPD and by the way one other point
forget everything else
it's about getting results right I'm
here to get things done and make life
better for people we got results last
night was a much much better night than
the night before so it worked we got
results let's just remember what we did
last night and let's keep that going
Webster County Executive the surging
business is there to ignore the faces
just suggested to them that they open up
right away if they so choose and he's
also starting the GoFundMe page to help
pay for any response to that well I
don't think telling people to violate
the law is a good idea and somebody
tells you to violate the law that's not
an excuse when you violate the law so
you still get the fine or whatever the
penalty is for violating the law you
would still be liable you would still
get sued and you will still be closed
down and you'll be penalized and you
know I can tell you yeah you should get
up and assault Jesse I think you should
do that yeah but you go to jail let's
take one more cheese Monahan of the NYPD
to apologize for just wondering what
what that conversation was like when you
spoke with the chief and again what how
did you come to that conclusion yeah I
make it very simple first I never spoke
to whatever that person's name is I
spoke to the police commissioner and
said the same thing I just said to you
and the same thing I said yesterday
which is it's an issue of management and
deployment the actual police officers
are the best my issue was with the
management and deployment never about
the police officers it's it's about the
management it's about the deployment not
about the officers thank you very much
[Applause]
taking my Bibles and I'm going back to
work
[Applause]
[Music]